>> STEVE: EMBATTLED EPAADMINISTA
>> STEVE: EMBATTLED EPAADMINISTO
>> STEVE: EMBATTLED EPAADMINIST
>> STEVE: EMBATTLED EPAADMINISTC
>> STEVE: EMBATTLED EPAADMINISTT
>> STEVE: EMBATTLED EPAADMINIST.
IS IN THE HEADLINES AFTER REPORT
DETAILING QUESTIONABLE TIES TO
LOBBYISTS AND CONCERNS ABOUT HIS
JUDGMENT ABOUT HIS TIME AS A
STATE SENATOR.
MARK SURE QUICKLY RESPONDED.
>> SCOTT'S DOING A PHENOMENAL
JOB.
PRESIDENTS HAPPY WITH HIM.
>> IT'S A HYPOTHETICAL QUESTION
IF HE WAS UNHAPPY.
>> STEVE: THE WIND WAS PART OF
THE DRAIN THE SWAMP AGENDA.
IN MANY WAYS HE HAS DELIVERED
BANNING OFFICIALS FROM LOBBING
FOR FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS AFTER
THEY LEAVE AND PREVENTING THEM
FROM LOBBING AGENCIES THEY
WORKED.
HE ALSO CUT REGULATION WHICH
MEANS LESS BUREAUCRACY AND LESS
OPPORTUNITY FOR LOBBYING.
THIS AGENDA SOME UNDERMINED WHEN
MEMBERS OF HIS OWN
ADMINISTRATION DON'T LIVE UP TO
THE STANDARDS.
HIS ABUSE OF POWER THIS WEEK ON
SWAMP WATCH.
>> WE TOOK TALK A LOT ABOUT
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS CASHING IN
ON THEIR TIME IN PUBLIC SERVICE
BY BECOMING LOBBYISTS AFTER THEY
LEAVE.
DESPITE PRESIDENT TRUMPS DREAM
THE SWAMP AGENDA IS STILL
HAPPENING.
UNDER SHOCKING NUMBER FORMER
LOBBYISTS NOW WORKING WITHIN THE
ADMINISTRATION AND REGULATING
THE SAME THAT THE SALON BEFORE.
THERE'S 60 WHO DID SO WITHIN
JUST TWO YEARS OF JOINING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
OF THE 60, 36 HAVE LOBBIED THE